quelle histoire raconte ses effets
éparpillés autour d'une valise ces
cahiers d'étudiants bilingue détrempée
par la pluie
voici tout ce qui reste de la vie passer
de l'un des clandestins arrivés hier
matin au prêcheur laguiole qui les a
menés s'est échouée fracassé par les
flots
on nous a signalé qu'il ya un arrivage
sur la plage canaux guetta iv et
malheureusement la mer était vraiment
démonter ce cas n'a été chaviré il y
avait combien de personnes à bord alors
on ne sait pas le nom exact mais ça peut
dépasser les six passagers quand même
pas cela ils savaient pas ils sont
arrivés vu l'état de la mer dont l'homme
se plus battu comme on dit une situation
qui au prêcheur fait presque partie du
quotidien
les yoles arrive de nuit ou tôt le matin
avec des immigrés haïtiens ou dominique
est souvent autour de ces ronds qui
arrive les gens ils descendent et après
ils ont compris ce qu'ils viennent
chercher ils sont cachés dans le bois
est plus tard il ya des gens qui
viennent me chercher c'est comme ça ça
se passe
ça arrive souvent au prochain emploi à
partir du moment qu'il pleut ils sont là
mais ils savent qu'il n'ya pas de
gendarmes il ya rien
il ya de la pluie mais profiteront d
arriver si fréquentes qu'un véritable
business semble s'être instauré autour
des clandestins une organisation pour
les récupérer ils ont leurs véhicules
les plus jeunes chiots concitoyens ils
leur demandent de l'argent non ben oui
oui c'est assez fréquent généralement
assez aux radios se sont dit si un fort
de france ça dépend ça dépend de ce
qu'ils ont sur eux
ça dépend de long pour sortir de
dominique arrivée à fort-de-france et
500 noms pour sortir ou de l'osce
belleville du prêcheur à fort-de-france
ceux qui viennent y chercher c'est pas
gratuit le business franchi parfois la
ligne de l'exploitation pure et simple
il y a quelques jours une filière de
trafic et prostitution de femmes
haïtiennes a été démantelé des
clandestins arrivés hier on est sans
nouvelles tous seraient vivants et se
sont volatilisés dans la nature